[Mark]- I never have. I've only played it once or twice when it first came out- and I never came back to it again
So I'm gonna play this, and then every time I die
I'm gonna-I'm gonna get out and I'm gonna check to see if I'm higher or lower in the queue cuz right now
I'm at three still but that's fine because I'm getting the content. You know what I mean?
I'm getting the sweet, delicious, content. So easy.
I have done a video on Geometry Dash - wait, I did it in the makeup challenge! That's right, didn't I?
Oh, I'm so pretty.
AHAHA
I did. I did do it. Okay, so we're gonna blast through this level because I'm really good at this game.
Oh-
Yaaay!
There we go- I'm number two. He-ey, I'm number two. I did it. I'm number-
*gibberish*
F u c k
*long sigh*
(slightly) Fuck...
Guys, 2! Yeah
All right. Okay, we're doing good. We're doing good, guys.
Okay, so I'm gonna load back up into the game and I'll check back in just a second.
Let's get the hard stuff in here. No, it's locked. Is it locked?
NANI?
Huh? Fingerdash!
Oh God, oh God, oh God!
Ho ha-ah!
Hahaha whaat?
*gasp* [voice crack] Uugh!
How would you do that?
What!?
What? What? What?
What? Uh- what?
Wai-wait a minute...
Wait a minute!
Don't "oof" me!
HOW?
Uh-
BUH-
But!
I can- I can't be any!
I can't possibly be any!
DON'T YOU "OOF" ME!
Oh, what did I do? I- oh..
Hold to dash?
What?
Ooohhh!
Learning mechanics that I probably should have learned in all the other levels leading up to this one!
Wow.
It all makes- oop
[Mark tries to sing along with the music playing in the background]
[But very much fails to do so]
Okay.
[Mark trying to sing along with the music playing in the background again ] (pompity)
POM
Buhdee
oh..
oof..
[Mark tries to sing AGAIN]
[Yeah he's still going]
i will eat some some
BiG
Pom budhee (you suck) OH, what place am I?
*angry noises*
FUCK! COCK! ASS! Let's go back into it
[Yeah he's singing it again, miserably]
Hauh... hoh
uhuhuhuhh
Just picked going crazy from waiting for going crazy in another way. Ah
frick [And with that he sings again]
God
3 God (its only game)
(why you have to be mad?)
I am not mad. I'm not.
Not. Definitely not.
[Yeah sure ,Mark]
Here we go
(OOF)
fuhuhuhuhuhh
hehehehe
Fuck you
OOF
fuck youuu
hahahahahaah
Pomp begens oh shit. Oh boy
Wow
Hey, I made it farther pump. Maybe it's French
BAM baguettes a oui Eiffel tower  ham baguettes
That we oui only do fromage
FUUU-, how'd I get that on the first try and then I can never get it ever again? Oh, really? Oh, okay
TWOOOOOOO
We're number two which means it'll just be another two hours. It's okay. I got this. All right, we're close
just like we're close to getting through this level
Maybe it's Portuguese
Fuck
God I thought I had that
Ah, I'm trying to sight-read it is not working, but I can do it
If you just let me concentrate if I concentrate my Chi I'm gonna get it. Everything else is just easy. This child's play. Oh
Yeah, easy easy easy as could be easy
easy, easy
Oh. I...missed...it?
*confused mark noises* wha- did i not get it???
What?! Oh I didn't jump there. Uh! Pam baguettes. Oh
AAWWWW
AAAAAWWWWWWWW!
Don't ooF MEE Oh what place am I? 2! all right. I'm still 2 which is good to know.
Ah shit, oh well.
I'm not mad. I'm glad I'm happy. I'm having a great hip happening in time
Did I? Oh I didn't..make it. Wait huh? Whack I'm confuzzled. Oh, I'm upside down
I gotta jump. Oh, that's what it is. Oh, I'm just dumb
Well much like the answer to....all my life's problems
The answer is I'm dumb. Is this too loud? By the way, I never asked this is too loud?
Is it too loud? Might be a bit too loud? I'm gonna turn it down. Just just a smell just a smell no
Well, I turned it down anyway, so whatever it's down now oh now it's too quiet
Oh so sad, although it's hard for a viewer. You never think about how we (dramatic pause)
Streamers have it how tough we have it with our with our big paychecks and our big mansions
So we all live in you know, how how we have to live, huh? It's hard. It's hard. It's hard
We have to endure this man. It's hard you guys ever have pity on us?
no, I don't think you ever do, you won't ever understand. Ow. (Chuckles)
Drivin' all of our Tesla's. Mark2702 's can't believe you would ever just not not
Appreciate what we go through every day playing video games. Oh, you think it's so easy, huh?
Well, I mean apparently not  according to what I'm doing. But yeah, whatever
All right. Oh fuck I shouldn't jump there. Oh, yeah, it's hard. Yeah. Thanks for the priest. Thanks at least someone preaches
Thanks for the priest with the 5 dollars attached. I swear
I'm not really an asshole cuz I swear it's just-it's all an act. It's an act. I was just an act.
Oh, really? I'm not really an asshole. I just you know sometimes
Yeah, where am I - okay. I'm number two still it's good
I do. I know I do. I know both of the game and both at life.
By the way, they brought back the referral program.
*laughing* They brought back the referral program for Teslas.
Mark 2702 is back in business, baby!
Imma actually, like, concentrate so I can not mess up?
Oh god I jumped! [Mark noises]
God, my twitchy finger my-my-
I don't like that. Mark two-seven. Everybody knows it. Everybody loves it.
Everybody loves-knows mark 2702 it is the premier code use it at every checkout possible and you'll find
magical discounts and eventually a free Tesla will show up at your door
God, dammit. Why am I doing this?
I'm just trying to kill time
But I'm building up stress that I'm gonna take out on the unfortunate people of no pixel City Los Santos
Now that I'm hearing it, I do hear cock baguettes. So I think it's French cock baguettes. Maybe this wee
Ken, all right, we're translating this slowly inch but surely listen to it
cock baguettes maybe this wee weekend
It's cock baguettes maybe this
wee [wee wee]
weekend
It's really it's really contemplative piece. The lyrics are beautiful
cock baguettes maybe this we
Come on. Hashtag cock baguette???
Not everything needs a hashtag but you know in this case I think you're absolutely right it absolutely does need a hashtag
AHH COME ON I JUUUUUUMPED
everyone heard it on my clacky ass  keyboard that I hate! Cock baguettes maybe this- FAIR IS NOT FAIR- when it comes to this game
The game is not fair. Therefore. It's not fair to say that this game is fair. It's not fair
I JUMPED
That was me that was me being a dummy. That was me being a dummy. That was me being a dummy
Owes me was just some dumb in my brain and I was dumb idk why I did that
That was dumb that was dumb of me and my brains is dumb my fingers too dumb
Every part me too dumb to even to contemplate doing anything about this
NOOOahHhhhhhhhhHHHHHhhhhhHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH god dammit
Either too early or too late turn earlier too late because I
overcompensated the last time that I didn't jump with an early jump and now I'm just stuck in purgatory because I'm too stupid to even
Contemplate doing it right!
No, don't jump on the third one, I'll man my finger just like twitched. Hey twitch dot TV
Have you ever heard a twitch prime man? What a competent Segway
Listen, if you haven't heard a twitch prime, it's this lovely lovely service that allows you for free
To subscribe to your favorite twitch streamer, it is just the best use code mark 2702
To double your free twitch Prime subscription today. Oh
God why my brain just like farted out because I thought I'd died
On the other thing because I was too high and then I was like for some reason I just went into a limb
Like kind of sensibility and I just fell over and died. Oh god. I'm so sick of this song
I'm so sick of cock baguettes. I can't yeah if I have to look at another cock baguette, it'll be the end of me.
Oh my god, oh my god. What is wrong with me? What is wrong with MEEE?
Why did I let go why would I let go why why did I let go?
New tera- ff..
*contemplates life choices which turns to singing*
What was that a troll
was that tricky? Was that tricky dicky? Was that some tricky dicky bullshit? Huh?
HUH?
(Nani?) I agree, nani indeed. No, I can't do practice mode. That's practically cheating Oh what place am I in?
WHAT?
FOUR???
Fucking I will I will sit here all goddamn day
I have other things that I was supposed to do today, but I will clear my fucking schedule to get in this goddamn server
I'm gonna farm all the sweet content that I need to get to get here. I will be here all
Fucking day so long as it gets me where I need to be which is in this goddamn server
I've been watching people play this for two
fucking weeks and I haven't been able to get in the server because of one bullshit thing or another but I am NOT gonna be
Thwarted by this inane. Oh, I didn't jump there not this inane bullshit, but that inane bullshit
I this is speed. This is the this is the the
The the sacrimoni was it called the the the the testament of the testament of Chet Brunsworth
I don't know whoever whatever character I play today in there. This is this is his cacophony. What is the word?
I can't ruin the the not the testimony. There's the the trials and tribulations, but that's not it. What's the word?
It's the word there word for it with
the the the the the thethe
The testicles, no, not that two of them not the manifest destiny. That's not the word nothing cock baguettes. No
It's like it's like a bibliography but not it's it's like this is the something that it's it's a word to describe
Like his story. What's the word? I can't can't look at chat at the moment
I'm a little busy but what there's a word for it. Ah
What's the word? It's hard. I can't think right now my brain is dedicated to this
Ah, what's the word but some attorney does the eulogy no biography memoir tribulation testimony tribulation. Is it Testament? No, uh,
No, no, it's like biography. No, it's not. It's not biography. No, dear god. That's not it. No
Autobio- it's not autobiography. I think it's Testament. This is the testament of Chet
Chet penis worth. The up bringing,  the manifesto the the prophecy the geography the the Treon
There's an is it there another word for it or is the Testament. What is it revelation?
The the Odyssey that's close Odyssey is close. It might be Testament, but that doesn't feel right
Chronicle, yes, this is the chronicle of Chet dicks worth chronicle. Like this is the chronic. That's the word
That's the word. I was looking for testament is close. They're all synonyms
but Chronicle
These are the chronicles of Chet Dicksworth and Chet Dicksworth is number two in this goddamn line
har anyway lemme concentrate on this
Oh
Come on
Ouu come on, I'm gonna get in this. I just got to remember that. This is not the end of my day. I don't suck
What what I didn't even see what happened it happened so fast I didn't even notice what was going on
What the fuck did I do I somehow recovered that I don't know how oh my god
I mean I died but I mean to recover the mistake that I made before which is letting go of the spacebar
So that's good. You guys did it didn't look like I did anything good but trust me something good came out of that
But I hit it!
But I hit it!!
I hate my life. I hate I hate my life hate hate my life hate my sweet life.
Fuck
No, don't uh, Frick doc Oh
Fuckin girl, let's do it again. Let's go get Khan
I don't have much time maybe or maybe I'm maybe I'm never getting in or maybe this is just another lie
I wouldn't be surprised if it was another lie
You know just another lie in the history of lies a long history of lives there comes in my life
Oh shit, oh fuck weird we're getting in
ohhohohohohohohohohohohoohohohhhohohohohohohohohoho
You